welcome back to Gary's economics today's
video is called teaching you how to
trade
okay so one of the most common comments
that we get on our videos is um
why do you bother making all these
videos trying to save the economy
if you're such a good Trader why don't
you just teach us all to trade and then
we could all be millionaires
um so I wanted to talk a little bit
about
trading about my trading about
teaching friends to trade and and
basically why I don't Focus the channel
on teaching how to trade so um
I was a Trader I spoken about a bit on
the channel
um from 2008 until 2014 I was a an
interest rate of a Citibank
um
in 2011 I was citibank's top Trader in
the world so I was a very
effective Trader I made a lot of money
for the bank I made a lot of money for
myself
um in 2014 I retired from
trading professionally and I didn't
actually do any trading for myself until
the end of 2017
um and that wasn't much and I didn't
really get back involved in trading
until the beginning of
covid so early 2020 about two and a half
years ago
um and I think that that should probably
tell you something in itself that even
though I was
a very successful professional Trader
once I quit I didn't really do
much trading at all for more than five
years myself individually and um
the main reason for that is that that
trading is really hard
um even if you're good at it uh you only
make money trading if you if you know
things that people other people don't
know if you have information other
people don't know some and artists other
people don't know and you're essentially
competing with other people who are
working full-time you know when I was a
full-time Trader I was up every day at
5am reading all the news you know I had
thousands of emails every day analysis
and I was reading all that analysis
talking to other Traders
looking at the economy all the time to
try and understand what was happening
and now
um you know in the last eight years
since I was a professional Trader you
know I do a lot of other things I sit at
home I'm not watching the news all the
time I'm not watching the markets all
the time and if I'm going to make money
Trading
I have to be competing with somebody who
is doing this full time every day so I
think you know you have to respect that
if you're if you think you can make
money trading you're saying you can
compete with
the best people who are working all the
time and as as me somebody now who still
follows markets a lot and still does
trade a lot I understand that I respect
that I'm not a full-time Trader anymore
so I don't take too many big risks
because I understand that me sitting
here you know making YouTube videos
seeing at home writing a book it's not
always in a position to compete with the
people who are fully watching it all the
time
um but that said at the beginning of
kovid there are a lot of like
I understood at the beginning of Kobe
that
the economy was not going to pan out the
way people thought it would and that was
because
generally as a Trader my belief was that
the significance of inequality on the
economy was not understood so when when
inequality changes massively you can
make money in the markets because
Traders and economists
um and participants in markets generally
don't understand
how big an effect the change inequality
will have on the economy and I think
covert was a massive opportunity for my
trading perspective
because if you were to look at the
beginning of kovid
it was very clear right at the beginning
of kovid that it was going to cause a
massive increase in inequality
but in general economists don't focus on
inequality even Traders um you know we
could talk about why they don't and I
think I'll probably put a video out you
know why economists don't look at
inequality but I knew at the beginning
of Kobe there was going to be a massive
increase in inequality I think anybody
who bothered to look at it could have
worked it out but because economists
don't look at it much they didn't really
realize that so because of that
you know I put a video out a few weeks
ago how inequality affects the economy
because we knew inequality was going to
increase massively we can make some
predictions about the economy we know
that for example asset prices will rise
because if a lot of money goes to rich
people rich people buy assets we know
that living standards will fall because
if Ordinary People Are Made poorer then
they can't spend as much stuff
that drives the economy down because
there's less spending and there's more
saving so very early on I was able to
predict massive increase in asset price
on a very weak economy
um at the beginning of kovid most
predictions whether asset prices would
fall and in fact many asset prices did
fall the gold price fell heavily stock
price itself fell heavily in general
most economists were predicting Big
Falls in house prices
um because I knew that the rich were
going to make a fortune I was able to
see well actually you know all of these
prices will go up a lot so it was a
massive trading opportunity and I put a
lot of money into buying assets at the
beginning of covid um mainly gold but
you know I bought a lot of things and
those things did go up and I did make a
lot of money
there was money to be made there because
economists don't understand significance
of inequality and um at the same time
it's doing that I wrote a lot of
articles
and I made videos basically saying that
these things were going to happen saying
that asset prices would go up saying
that the gold price would go up and some
friends of mine saw the articles I was
putting out and they said hey you know
like I'm a bit worried because you're
saying house price is going to go up and
I don't have a house um you know what
can I do and um
you know I met with them and I just told
them what I was doing which was you know
I'm I'm putting some bets on asset
prices going up and you can do that in
these various ways you know full
disclosure I use gambling sites online
to make my bets um and I told my friends
I was doing that and they said well you
know what are you betting on and and my
big bet was that the gold price would go
up so I told these guys you know I'm
betting the gold price will go up and
the gold price did go up the gold price
went up massively and I made quite a lot
of money
um but what is interesting is so I'm
thinking of two friends now um they'll
probably watch this video and laugh um
who I told them that we're gonna
I'm big on the gold price and and they
went out and they did the same thing and
what is really interesting is what
happened to both of these friends was
quite similar which was I told them okay
gold price is going to go up this time
back on the gold price this is how you
do it they went off in their bit on the
gold price and then the gold price went
up and up and up and up and up and
eventually maybe about six months later
I had quite a shop fall but it's still
massively higher than when I put it on
so you know you're up money but you've
lost a bit of money
um and both of my friends called me up
separately and they were like oh my God
Gary what do I do
and I was like well
you know you don't do anything you know
we made a lot of money and then we lost
a bit of money and overall we've still
made a lot of money and they were like
in both cases they said no you don't
understand that I'm out right I'm out
I've I've lost everything
and it was like
how have you managed to lose money when
like the position is way above where I
told you and it's super interesting like
psychologically both people did pretty
much the exact same thing I told them
the gold price are going to go up and
initially they didn't do anything and
they waited for the gold price to go up
quite a lot and then they were like oh
my God Gary was right let's buy gold
then they went in and they bought a load
of gold and the price went up a bit
further
and then now they've made a lot of money
and in both cases they thought oh my God
I'm a genius I've got an amazing trade
and they started to put on loads and
loads of Trades which were nothing to do
with anything that I told them because
they made a bit of money trading and
they and they started to develop this
sort of false confidence in their
ability as a Trader even though they
made money on exactly the trade that I I
advise them they developed an
overconfidence that meant they started
to put a lot more trades on put a lot
more bets on increase the size of their
bets and then when it came down a little
bit the other bits which they put on
were basically to the same bet in other
ways everything came down and they ran
out of money and that basically made me
realize
how diff how dangerous it is to teach
people how to trade because
trading is a crazy thing and if you look
at what these people did
it's quite mad what they did right
because they had a trading
recommendation from me like a formerly
very successful professional Trader what
they should have done is just done the
thing that I told them to do but they
didn't do that right they it first they
didn't listen to the advice they waited
till it moved and then they got in then
when it moved a bit further they kind of
thought
it was because of their ability and they
developed a sort of false understanding
a false belief that they themselves are
very good Traders when in reality they
were just copying a tip that they got
from me and it was really just one trade
and they put a load of stuff on so
from my
since then I've
we saw that the massive what I think is
a bubble in crypto
um which which did a similar thing to a
lot of people right A lot of people got
dragged into this thing they bet on it
going up it did go up they got
overconfident they they made bigger bets
and then it collapsed and a lot of
people lost a lot of money and I was
worried about that happening so I got in
touch with a guy called Matt Zab cousin
who got an interview with him on the
channel and he runs
an organization to help people with
gambling addiction and I said to him
look
I knew in covert there'd been a massive
increase in people doing using online
trading platforms and also betting on
cryptocurrencies and I I said to him
have you seen an increase in
problem gambling which is not coming
through the traditional ways Sports
gambling uh you know online casino
things
um and it's coming through online
trading and cryptocurrencies and he said
massively we have seen a massive
increase of people who are losing money
online trading and cryptocurrencies
um
so then I saw then
loads of people at that time crypto was
still in a boom right and everybody was
super excited about it so I started
talking about crypto on the news trying
to tell people to avoid it we made a
video about crypto on the channels
trying to tell people to avoid it that
is still my stance if you should avoid
it I think it's a extremely dangerous
investment if you could I wouldn't even
call it an investment really
um
and then I started getting messages from
from people who'd been getting involved
in crypto and very often what the
messages said were
you know I I got involved in trading
crypto and you know I was doing really
well but you know I made a mistake and
I've lost all my money and I was
wondering if you could give me some
advice on how to trade it in the future
and you know I want you to sort of
sit back and think about that message
right because these are people who got
involved in something which you know I
think is just basically a fraudulent
asset doesn't really exist it's pure con
they've lost all their money
and their plan is to keep trading it
you know when I see the you know and
whenever I get these messages it's it's
difficult to apply to all my messages
nowadays but when I get these ones I try
to take the time just to send them a
message back saying listen you need to
understand that what you have is a
gambling addiction and you need to stop
doing that you need to you need to never
trade crypto again
um
but what we have here is a situation
where
the way that these trading platforms are
designed
um
they're designed to be very very
addictive and they show you all these
lines going up lines going down lots of
lots of information lots of data lots of
charts you can draw lines on lots of
analysis you can do lots of news they
want to give you the impression that you
are
a Trader you are an expert but the truth
is
when you watch some videos on YouTube
and draw some lines on some charts and
you sit down at your laptop and you do
online trading you are competing against
me and you're competing against people
like me who have been who have been
waking up at 5am every day for 15 years
reading thousands of email doing all the
analysis with um with massive Banks
behind them massive amounts of money
behind them
um
and I think to think that you can make
money Trading
you know just because even you watch my
videos on YouTube
would be a little bit like me you know
going into simran and saying you know
I've been watching some videos
on YouTube and I think maybe I can win
the 100 meters at the Olympics next year
you know like it's difficult it's
difficult and even I
limit the amount of risk I take because
I know you know I'm making a YouTube I'm
writing the book I'm busy with stuff and
I don't have the time to throw into it
and it's and that's even me
I have made money trading but you know
I've got a massive amount of cash in my
bank account you know what I mean in my
and in my trading account if I lose
money I can add more money in
so I think
if you come in with you know 200 300
Grand then you are formerly an extremely
successful professional Trader
even then I'm saying you should be
careful but if you come in with five ten
Grand and you've got no professional
experience
number one
if you're coming in with 10 15 grand
it's going to be impossible to make any
realistic amount of money without taking
insane amounts of risk
and number two
you're probably gonna end up losing
money because in the end trading is a
zero-sum game right and you need to ask
yourself who are likely to be the
winners and who are likely to be the
losers when it comes to you versus the
professionals who have all the
information I know the experience
so on IG index on the home page they
always show like the percentage of of
accounts that lose money and I remember
when crypto is at the very very topic
came down to as low as 60 only 60 of
accounts were losing money since the
crypto collapse 77 of accounts on that
website lose money and
you know I'm on that website I'm making
money I'm a professional
former profession with a lot of
experience
you need to ask yourself
realistically is this a way that that I
can make money that we can make money
and um
my concern really is that websites like
this
are taking advantage of a situation
where it's increasingly very very
difficult for ordinary people to
make any decent money or even to get
Financial Security really and at the
same time because there's so much
inequality
we have to live in a world where despite
the fact you might not be able to make a
lot of money and Ordinary People are
finding it really difficult to make
money there are a lot of super rich
people around you and wealthy people who
who are normally getting that money from
from their parents so that creates a
situation where it's very very difficult
because ordinary people have to struggle
whilst watching rich people all around
them
um and I think that creates a
vulnerability that is really being
exploited by these websites selling you
a dream like
we'll get into our website you can do
trading you can make a ton of money
um
and look I would love I would love to be
able to sell you a bunch of trading tips
and you go out there and you'll become
millionaires but look
if it was that easy you know I would be
a lot richer than I am you know what I
mean you know I put a decent amount of
money into trading and I make some money
from it
um and I don't put more because because
it's super difficult and not and it's
too risky you know and and that's
someone like me who has money to lose so
you know investing is a different thing
um there's already a video on the
channel called basics of investing I
would encourage anyone if it's possible
to try and save as much money as you can
and build that up into real assets
stocks gold property if it's possible
whilst always understanding that even
those Investments can lose money and in
many cases will lose money over short
periods of time
um I would encourage anyone to do that
if you want to know about investing
watch that video but you need to
understand trading it's not investing
trading is gambling trading is super
dangerous
um I was a professional Trader and even
I severely limit the amount of trading
that I do because it's dangerous and
because it's risky so um
you know the reason that I do this
channel is because
I don't think it's possible
for the majority of ordinary families to
to move to financial stability in a
system which is gradually and
increasingly quickly draining the wealth
away from ordinary families in the
middle class to all the super rich I
look at the system and so here is a
system which is guaranteeing poverty for
most people
um if we don't fix that most people are
going to be poor and
unfortunately trading on the internet
from what I see and you know from what
the number on IG index tells me for the
majority of people it's a losing
proposition most people are losing money
and I see a lot of those people in my
inbox and I don't want you to be one of
those people and um you know I wish I
wish I could just put some tips here
that are going to make you a millionaire
you know and I could tell you the trades
I've got on you know I'm betting that
the gold price will rise in a number of
currencies right but I've told people
that's it before and they've gone and
they've lost money it is difficult I
wouldn't recommend it if you want to
know about investing
um there's an investing video on this
channel basis of investing we've worked
with conversation and money before who
talks about personal finances of course
you can go and you can watch Martin
Lewis
um
but the truth of the situation is we
have a big systemic problem here which
is making Ordinary People poorer and
poorer um increasingly I think if
ordinary people do not get involved in
politics they will lose all of their
wealth um another one that to happen so
I'm very sorry for not teaching how to
trade in this video
um
but the fact of the matter is
the economy is getting worse and worse
and you cannot Escape that you know it's
it's not
it's not viable as somebody with no
experience in trading to think I will
escape this by getting involved in
trading we're seeing a lot of people
lose a lot of money by trying to do that
77 of of users of ignix lose money
we're seeing a lot of people who are
trying to get involved in crypto lose
money
um look there's a big systemic problem
here it's making everybody poorer whilst
the rich and the super rich gets get
much much richer if we don't do anything
about that that's going to be you your
family or community so I want to stop
that and you know I would like you to
support me so
let's try and make things better in a
way that's actually going to work
instead of a way that's going to offer
you money and end up bankrupting you
which is always doing to a lot of people
so yeah um
trading's risky
um but fixing the economy is is
something that could work for everyone
so let's work towards it thank you
happy with that
we've created a generation of young men
who have had wealth and financial
success shoved down their throats for
their whole childhoods and have no
legitimate means of getting those things
there's one other thing they can do with
that massive amount of income
they can buy your mom's house
[Music]